exiger son retrait immédiat du
territoire arménien a fait respecter
l'accord de cesser le feu du 9 novembre
2020 et favoriser toute initiative
visant à établir une paix durable entre
les deux pays présenté par les
présidents Bruno Retailleau Christian
Cambon madame la Présidente
Monsieur les présidents Patrick
et Gilbert Luc de village
dans la discussion générale je donne la
parole au président Bruno Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cette résolution que nous vous proposons
d'adopter
est une nouvelle résolution je dis
nouvelle parce qu'elle fait écho à une
résolution que nous avions déjà adopté
il y a très précisément deux ans il y a
deux ans nous avions adopté une
résolution pour l'Arménie pour la paix
en Arménie pour condamner l'agression
sur le haut-karaba commise par les
azéries avec le soutien turc bien sûr et
déjà cette résolution avait fait l'objet
d'un accueil multi partisan elle avait
été consignée par plusieurs présidents
de groupe et vous permettrez en
commençant mon intervention de saluer
les précisions de groupe qui ont
consigné cette résolution je voudrais
saluer bien évidemment les deux
présidents qui sont présidents Christian
Combon et Gilbert Luc de vinasse pour le
président du groupe d'amitié aussi
d'avoir à poser leur signature si la
démarche avait déjà été elle est
une démarche transpartisane cela
signifie bien que en réalité l'enjeu
qu'il y a derrière cette résolution
dépasse les clivage habituel faut-il
rappeler que ceux qui se joue
concerne les intérêts français tout
autant que nos propres principes tout
autant que nos propres valeurs je veux
rappeler les liens les liens humains les
liens d'amitié multicellulaire qui
unissent nos deux peuples je veux aussi
rappeler les liens culturels faut-il
redire ici que le dernier un des grands
sommets de la Francophonie s'est
déroulée en 2018 en Arménie justement
hayerevan et si nous avions pris il y a
deux ans cette initiative c'est tout
simplement que déjà nous ne faisions pas
confiance dans l'accord de paix qui
avait été alors signé le 10 novembre
2020 et l'effet malheureusement nous ont
donné raison puisque
l'Azerbaïdjan profitant de la guerre en
Ukraine a ATT cette fois-ci ce qui est
encore beaucoup plus grave non seulement
le ok rabat mais surtout l'Arménie sur
son sol même comme il y a deux ans et si
j'ose dire malheureusement comme à
l'habitude les chancellerie ont protesté
mollement
par pure forme comme à l'habitude il y a
eu malheureusement des crimes de guerre
ces crimes de guerre ont été à nouveau
documentés mais il y a eu aucune
sanction monsieur le ministre je n'ai
rien contre vous mais franchement et
j'ai tout pour mon pays est beaucoup de
considérations pour le commerce
extérieur mais quelle signification
attache le gouvernement à cette
résolution à la cause de l'Arménie en
déléguant le ministre du comice
extérieur au banc du gouvernement c'est
une légèreté une désinvolture que je
regrette et mes chers collègues je ne
suis pas seul ici à la regretter
bien sûr une mission d'observation a été
dépêchée mais le temps n'est plus le
temps n'est plus à observer il est
désormais à décider le temps n'est plus
à protester il est à sanctionner ses
précisément ce que propose cette
résolution cette résolution est le
propose tout simplement pour ne pas
laisser seul pour ne pas laisser seul
avec son malheur l'Arménie et tout
abandon signifierait pour nous une honte
plus même
ce que devrait nous inspirer un abandon
c'est la crainte c'est un sentiment de
peur
l'abandon d'abord et la honte ce que je
veux dire c'est souligner ce de poids de
mesure comment se fait-il que la Russie
viole le droit international violent la
souveraineté de l'Ukraine et les
condamné bien sûr elle subit justement
des sanctions rien rien pour les Éric
badges rien pour la Turquie encore une
fois la Russie viole le droit de la
guerre il y a eu des crimes de guerre en
Ukraine il y en a aussi en harmonie et à
nouveau alors que dans un cas ces crimes
sont poursuivis en Arménie rien ne se
passe ce deux poids de mesure les chers
collègues c'est une véritable honte
c'est une honte parce que qu'est-ce que
cela signifie est-ce que cela signifie
vraiment que la souveraineté de
l'Arménie vaut moins que la souveraineté
de l'Ukraine est-ce que cela signifie
que les commence les vices ukrainiennes
les vies pardon Armagnac vanne moins que
les vies ukrainiennes que ces
souffrances
ukrainiennes bien sûr que non et il y a
eu presque pire lorsque la présidente de
la Commission européenne c'est rendu à
bas coût pour signer un accord gazier
alors que dans le même cas évidemment le
gaz russe est frappé de sanctions
où sont les belles âmes où sont les
protestations des grandes consciences
pourquoi finalement ce silence c'est un
scandale moral est-ce qu'on a le moral
que seuls peuvent justifier à la fois
une forme de cynisme une forme de
relativisme d'une Europe oublieuse
oublieuse non seulement de ses valeurs
de ces principes oublieuses aussi de ses
propres racines mes chers collègues si
ce sentiment de honte nous est étrangers
alors peut-être que un sentiment de
crainte de peur pourrait nous saisir
quel est ce sentiment de crainte ou ce
sentiment de peur tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui on le voit bien le
contexte géopolitique l'équilibre
géopolitique européen était branlé par
l'impérialisme russe à l'est sur le
flanc Est de l'Europe et bien demain ce
même équilibre géopolitique pourrait
l'être aussi par un autre impérialisme
par l'impérialisme turc cette fois-ci
sur le flanc sud de l'Europe que
ferons-nous parce que là encore n'en
doutait pas un seul instant ce conflit
n'est pas un conflit local il s'inscrit
dans une stratégie turque globale où il
s'agit de reconstituer un grand ensemble
ottoman un ensemble penture que c'est ce
que dit d'ailleurs est-ce que répète à
l'envie il suffit de l'écouter le
président de la Turquie monsieur Erdogan
lorsque il dit que les deux pays
l'Azerbaïdjan et la Turquie sont en
réalité deux États mais une seule et
même nation c'est pas moi qui le dis
c'est Monsieur
Erdogan et ce plan le plan qu'il a avec
ce allié à Zeri se déroule c'est un plan
en trois étapes d'abord l'attaque de
zerbaïdjan tenter pardon d'abord
l'attaque du au carabaque tenter
évidemment de vider le ok bac de sa
population d'effacer les traces
d'arménité de ce territoire premier état
deuxième étape transpercer de part en
part l'Arménie grâce à un couloir qui
relierait la kitvan pour relier
évidemment les deux territoires aziris
d'une part et turcs d'autre part et puis
malheureusement la dernière étape ce
serait l'Arménie elle-même l'effacement
de la carte de l'Europe de cette nation
de ce de ce peuple et de cette état ce
qui fait chers amis la singularité
tragique de l'Arménie c'est que ce
peuple porte la marque et porte à jamais
cette marque indélébile du génocide
que voulons nous faire quels sont les
choix que nous avons devant nous quel
est l'alternative nous avons un premier
choix qui serait celui de ne pas choisir
de ne rien faire comme à l'habitude ce
choix ce serait un choix funeste ce
serait le choix en réalité à la fois
comme l'avait dit un jour Churchill du
déshonneur et de la défaite du
déshonneur parce que nous ne saurions
pas à la hauteur de nos principes nous
ne serions pas à la hauteur de notre
histoire et puis nous aurions la défaite
parce que face à une Turquie face un
Azerbaïdjan qui nous réserve qu'en
rapport de force que croyez-vous qu'il
arrivera demain au moment voit très très
bien les mener Turcs notamment avec la
Grèce dans la médiathèque année
orientale finalement dans cet espace
géographique qui concerne non seulement
l'Europe comme un continent mais qui
concerne l'Europe aussi en tant que
Union européenne c'est la raison pour
laquelle je parle non seulement de
déshonneur mais aussi d'une défaite
probable demain soit il y a un autre
chemin et c'est ce que nous vous
proposons de suivre avec cette
résolution c'est le chemin du courage
c'est un chemin où il s'agit de montrer
à l'Arménie notre solidarité plutôt que
notre passivité où il s'agit de montrer
aussi notre fermeté plutôt que de
laisser aller les choses telles que
souvent nous avons laissé aller bien
entendu cette réaction passe à travers
des sanctions des sanctions par exemple
pour geler les avoir des dirigeants des
dirigeants notamment azéri passent aussi
par un embargo sur le pétrole sur le gaz
mais ces sanctions devraient passer
monsieur le ministre par une action
diplomatique une action politique
résolue de la France notre pays en
raison notamment de ces liens de
d'amitié des réactions d'abord pour que
il y ait un rapatriement de tous les
prisonniers Arméniens sur le sol
arménien une action ensuite pour que
nous saisissions le Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU pour que nous puissions saisir
aussi là ces pays la Cour pénale
internationale pour que les crimes de
guerre ne restent pas impuni une action
toujours diplomatique de la France pour
que et y est non pas une force
d'observation d'ailleurs les deux mots
sont antinomiques mais plutôt une
mission d'interposition une mission
d'interposition sur le sol du au
carabaque et puis de l'Arménie et enfin
et c'est aussi important que la France
puisse aider avec des armes défensives
les Arméniens vraiment à pouvoir se
défendre je conclurai mes chers
collègues en vous rappelant que c'est la
France qui le premier pays grâce à
Jacques Chirac avait reconnu le génocide
arménien et que c'est en première
lecture monsieur le Président ici au
Sénat que la loi de reconnaissance avait
été votée il y a 20 ans il y a deux ans
c'est nous au Sénat premier rassemblée
parlementaire d'Europe et du monde qui
avons les premiers votés à cette quasi
unanimité moins une voix cette
résolution qui était aussi un signal un
geste vis-à-vis du peuple arménien alors
aujourd'hui l'Arménie appelle à nouveau
la France à son secours soyons fidèles à
cet appel soyons fidèle à ce sentiment
d'amitié à notre histoire nous principes
parce que il en va de ce lien séculaire
multicellaire qui nous unit à ce peuple
à ce grand peuple l'Arménie était un
peuple courageux peuple courage une
petite nation mais une grande nation
parce que c'est une nation sentinelle
d'une belle civilisation c'est aussi un
pays par lequel nous relie ces liens
encore une fois qui ont traversé les
générations qui ont traversé les siècles
des liens qui tout autant tiennent par
notre amitié que parce que nous sommes
les vis-à-vis des autres merci mes chers
collègues merci monsieur le président
la parole aux présidents Patrick canaire
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
monsieur le Président Monsieur ministre
mes chers collègues cette proposition de
résolution à une première vertu comme
d'ailleurs vient de le rappeler le
président retaillod outre la possibilité
qui nous est offerte ici de débattre et
de réaffirmer les positions qui sont les
nôtres pour aller vers une paix durable
elle nous permet cette résolution de
d'apporter notre soutien soutien sans
faille au peuple en souffrance au peuple
qui ploie sous le jou de la guerre sous
le joug du nationalisme nous
n'exprimerons jamais assez notre total
solidarité à l'égard de la population
armée arménienne comme le fait depuis
toujours notre groupe socialiste
écologiste la républicain une population
victime du conflit de 2020 qui a fait
plus de 6500 morts
et les dernières escalades meurtrières
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour saluer ici
l'action inlassable de notre collègue
Gilbert Luc de vinaz à la tête du
président du groupe d'amitié France
Arménie merci à Monsieur de village
[Applaudissements]
ce peuple qui a tant souffert doit voir
revenir dans ses foyers tous les
éloignés nous appelons ici la libération
u rapatriement immédiat et
inconditionnel de tous les présidents
des présidents de guerre Arméniens du
territoire de l'Arménie du couloir de la
Chine nous demandons le retrait immédiat
et inconditionnel sur leur position
initiale des forces Algérie de leurs
alliés les autorités azzeries et
l'ensemble de leurs partenaire dans la
région doivent respecter l'intégrité
territoriale la souveraineté
l'indépendance de l'Arménie les
engagements internationaux existent ils
doivent être suivis des faits à
l'évidence le cadre de sécurité dans
lequel est entré l'Arménie depuis le
cessez-le-feu lui assure un faux
semblant de sécurité puisque cela n'a
échappé à personne l'Azerbaïdjan a tenté
de maximiser ses gains territoriaux le
statu quo n'est pas possible ainsi nous
ne pouvons que regarder avec intérêt les
premières évolutions que la que l'on a
pu constater ces dernières semaines
les parlementaires ont toute leur place
nous avons toute notre place mes chers
collègues dans la contribution à la
réduction des tensions déjà notre
précédente résolution votait le 25
novembre 2020 avec votre voyage monsieur
le Président merci de l'avoir convié
quelques-uns d'entre nous à vous
accompagner déjà cette précédente
résolution portée sur la nécessité de
reconnaître la République du okarabaq et
a été un élément de soutien très
apprécié très apprécié par le peuple et
les autorités arméniennes aujourd'hui il
semble que manifester fermement notre
détermination en faveur de la règlement
pacifique du conflit a eu quelques
effets cette contribution peut être même
jouer à un rôle de sensibilisation du
chef de l'État de la République
française par ailleurs réunir fin
octobre à Sotchi les deux parties autour
de la table les faire se parler avancer
ensemble vers une résolution pacifique
est un nouveau pas qui va dans le sens
recherché
pour autant mes chers collègues il
convient de rester attentif ce conflit
ne peut être l'otage de l'instabilité
dans le Caucase et des stratégies
développées par les grandes puissances
régionales nous l'avons constaté la
médiation russe de la force
d'interposition de l'Organisation du
Traité de la sécurité collective n'est
plus en mesure de stabiliser le conflit
ni à moyen ni à long terme la France au
sein de l'Union européenne monsieur le
ministre doit jouer son rôle le
président de la République a bougé sur
ce dossier tant mieux mais il doit
bouger encore plus vite et l'Europe avec
lui l'Union européenne doit adopter sa
propre stratégie vis-à-vis du conflit
entre l'Arménie laser abadjan en
conditionnant les achats de gaz à
l'Azerbaïdjan au respect du droit
international
le gouvernement doit amplifier ses
initiatives permettant de garantir la
sécurité des populations arméniennes et
de l'Arménie dans ses frontières
internationalement reconnues pour cela
il doit agir au niveau le plus haut car
il est impératif de constituer une force
de maintien de la paix sous l'égide de
l'ONU et de l'OSCE il faut par exemple
saluer l'initiative de l'Arménie
lorsqu'elle propose une zone démitarisée
au carabaques et à sa frontière avec la
gerbaïdjan
au plus long terme l'Union européenne
doit intégrer le conflit arménien dans
le cadre de la gestion des tensions
régionales dans un périmètre plus large
les déflagrations dans la région qui
s'étendent de l'Europe orientale à
l'Asie centrale son susceptibles d'avoir
des répercussions sur les États voisins
de l'Europe qui lui sont ou qui lui
seront liés un jour par des partenariats
mes chers collègues en défendant cette
résolution
nous manifestons notre soutien un
règlement pacifique du conflit et au
maintien des principes de démocratie
d'État de droit au sein de ces deux
états qu'il faut d'ailleurs il faut
rappeler que ces deux états en
belligérance sont membres du Conseil de
l'Europe organe garant et promoteur de
ses valeurs dans une Europe élargie mes
chers collègues tout doit être mis en
œuvre pour que la gerbaïdjan s'engage
plus en avant dans un processus de
négociation par la voie diplomatique
il est temps de retourner à la raison de
retrouver la voie du dialogue il est
temps de satisfaire l'Arménie les
Arméniens dans leur volonté d'une paix
juste il est temps d'aboutir enfin
établissement d'une paix durable dans
cette région du monde avec cette
résolution soyons en convaincus nous
prenons finalement un peu notre part je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]
je vais appeler maintenant cette tribune
notre collègue Pierre ouzoullias pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
septembre une délégation du Sénat a été
reçue à Erevan par les autorités
arméniennes notre collègue et amis le
député Vladimir vardaniane président du
groupe d'amitié France Arménie France
nous a dit les larmes aux yeux sa
terreur de ne pouvoir éviter à son
peuple un second génocide
en octobre 2019 nous étions tous les
deux dans la clairière du Mont Valérien
la même ou Missak manoucheillet par les
Allemands le 21 février 1944
Missak Manouchian a donné sa vie pour la
liberté de la France comme sommes-nous
près à donner à l'Arménie pour sa
liberté
du 27 septembre au 10 novembre 2020 la
République darsar a subi l'invasion
militaire de l'Azerbaïdjan
aidé par la Turquie et renforcé par des
groupes djihadistes venant de Libye et
de Syrie la Turquie a ainsi participé au
moins indirectement un conflit de haute
intensité selon une doctrine et des
processus militaires qu'elle a appris au
sein de l'OTAN
ce sont les mêmes tactiques que
l'Ukraine utilise aujourd'hui avec
succès contre l'invasion russe ainsi les
drones Turcs by raktar TB2 engagé par
l'Ukraine sont aussi ceux mobilisés par
l'Azerbaïdjan contre l'Arménie Israël
fournit aussi des drones aux deux armées
la République darsar et l'Arménie ont
été totalement dépassés par l'ampleur et
la violence de ce conflit d'un nouveau
genre elles n'ont dû leur survie qu'à la
mansétude de la Russie qui voulait
démontrer en 2020 que la sécurité du
Caucase ne dépendait qu'elle que d'elle
c'est sans aucun doute le désastre
militaire de l'armée russe en Ukraine
qui pousse aujourd'hui laser badjan a
profité de son avantage pour imposer par
la force à l'Arménie un redécoupage des
frontières internationales à son profit
son objectif stratégique est connu il
consiste à établir une continuité
territoriale avec sa république autonome
esclavée du naritchevan en annexant à
corriderm un corridor le long de la
frontière entre l'Arménie et l'Iran
cette ambition n'est qu'une déclinaison
régionale du grand projet pont Turquie
de constitution d'un espace politique
unifié
d'Istanbul à Biscaye au Kirghizistan en
octobre la France par la voie de son
président a explicitement caractérisé
les agressions de l'Azerbaïdjan comme
une violation des frontières arméniennes
reconnues par le droit international il
est affligent qu'en juillet la
présidente de la Commission européenne
se soit rendue à bas coût pour sceller
un accord énergétique avec l'Azerbaïdjan
qualifié de partenaires de confiance
l'Azerbaïdjan exporte plus de pétrole
qui n'en produit et vont sans doute à
l'Europe une partie du pétrole qu'elle
reçoit de la Russie elle sait aussi
engagée à doubler ses exportations de
gaz vers l'Europe et le principal
chantier azéri et notamment exploité par
la compatie par la compagnie russe look
oil nous sommes prêts à oublier tous nos
principes moraux quand il s'agit
d'assurer la sécurité des approvisionnes
zonement énergétiques de l'Europe et
singulièrement sur l'Allemagne depuis
plus d'un siècle l'Arménie et le miroir
de nous l'acheter de nos hypocrisies et
de nos trahisons
aussi nous sommes très favorables à
cette résolution qui demande notamment
au gouvernement de mobiliser sa
diplomatie pour obtenir de l'Union
européenne un embargo sur le pétrole et
le gaz provenant d'Azerbaïdjan mais
au-delà comment assurer durablement la
survie de l'Arménie de nombreux
Arméniens pensent trouver leur sécurité
sous la toux telle russe et le
catholicos de l'Église apostolique
arménienne vient de recevoir de Vladimir
Poutine les insignes de Lord de
l'honneur le soutien de la Russie a déjà
été défaillant par le passé aujourd'hui
son intérêt stratégique est de prolonger
ce conflit pour maintenir l'Arménie dans
un état de subordination et faire valoir
cette protection relative dans une
négociation plus ample de nouveau les
conflits ukrainiens et Arméniens sont
liés
pour aider durablement l'Arménie il
revient la France et à l'Europe de poser
les bases d'un nouveau multilatéralisme
à l'échelle de tout le continent
européen et de son proche environnement
cette réflexion ne peut éluder les
problèmes posés par nos relations avec
la Turquie et de son projet
expansionniste son appartenance à l'OTAN
ne justifie pas l'abdication collective
de l'Europe face à l'agression turque
contre l'Arménie mais aussi c'est
manœuvres contre la Grèce et
l'occupation militaire d'une partie du
territoire de la République de Chypre
avant d'être fusillés missac Manouchian
écrivait à sa femme je suis sûr que le
peuple français et tous les combattants
de la liberté seront honorés notre
mémoire dignement
aujourd'hui le peuple arménien nous
demande de rester fidèle au combat de la
France pour la liberté et le droit des
peuples à disposer de même merci merci
mon cher collègue
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jacques le nez pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste
la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2020
plusieurs semaines de combat ont déchiré
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan pendant
lesquels plus de 6500 personnes ont été
tuées les armes se sont ensuite tu à la
suite d'un Cécile feu publié le 10
novembre 2020 depuis des affrontements
sporadiques ont eu lieu au cours de
l'année 2021 plus récemment dans la nuit
du 12 au 13 septembre dernier le Cécile
feu a de nouveau été rompu
l'Azerbaïdjan a envoyé les troupes sur
le territoire arménien où elles se sont
installées une réponse à des
provocations arméniennes selon Bakou le
bilan est tout de même de 286 morts
et malheureusement ces affrontements de
septembre les plus violents depuis 2020
ne s'apparente pas à des incidents
isolés la semaine dernière les deux pays
se sont accusés mutuellement de
bombardements frontaliers pour ma part
au nom du groupe Union centrisme je
condamne le recours à la force qui ne
peut être un outil de résolution
des différents entre des états tout
particulièrement lorsqu'ils sont membres
de même instance internationales comme
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan membres du
Conseil de l'Europe du Partenariat
oriental de l'Union européenne est plus
récemment de la communauté politique
européenne
afin de trouver le chemin de la paix
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie
doit être respectée et préserver et
l'Azerbaïdjan doit donc se retirer du
territoire arménien conformément
l'accord de cesser le feu de novembre
2020 ainsi qu'à la déclaration
d'almahata de 1981
les deux États doivent ainsi respecter
leurs engagements internationaux et
s'appelait à négocier rapidement un
accord de paix durable conforme à ces
engagements et qui devra être respecté
monsieur le ministre le 6 octobre
dernier lors du sommet de Prague et de
la première réunion de la communauté
politique européenne un premier pas été
franchi en faveur d'un dialogue entre
les deux états il a été décidé de
l'envoi d'une mission civile en Arménie
le long de la frontière avec
l'Azerbaïdjan afin d'établir une
confiance mutuelle entre les deux pays
et de contribuer à la délimitation de
frontières pérenne entre les deux états
belligérants
quels sont les premiers retours de cette
mission placée sous les gîtes de l'Union
européenne monsieur le ministre l'Union
européenne veut jouer un rôle de
médiateur dans le règlement de ce
conflit elle est en même temps soumise à
de forts enjeux stratégiques en matière
d'autonomie
énergétique conséquences directes de la
guerre en Ukraine et des sanctions
imposées à la Russie
l'Union européenne a d'ailleurs signé
cet été un nouveau partenariat
énergétique avec l'Azerbaïdjan
renforçant donc ses relations
bilatérales avec le pays dès lors comme
comment être certain que l'Union
européenne pourra jouer son rôle
d'arbitre sans être contrainte par des
ventuelles pression
je souhaite également attirer votre
attention sur la préservation du
patrimoine du haut carabac cette région
constitue l'un des berceaux de notre
humanité et elle est en péril dans un
rapport sénatorial sur le haut carabac
dont je salue la qualité notre assemblée
alerté déjà en juillet 2021 sur le
risque de destruction du petit
patrimoine témoin de l'emprunt
d'arménienne de la région la communauté
internationale et la France ne doivent
pas cautionner la politique de
destruction du patrimoine culturel et
religieux arménien visant à effacer
toute trace de la culture arménienne
monsieur le ministre le Sénat c'est
toujours tenu aux côtés de l'Arménie en
son témoin les différentes résolutions
transpartisanes examinées dans cette
hémicycle notre groupe votera dans sa
grande majorité en faveur de cette
révolution
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Jean-Louis Masson pour les
collègues n'appartenant à aucun groupe
monsieur ministre chers collègues
face à l'agression scandaleuse dont
l'Arménie est victime l'inaction des
États-Unis de l'Union européenne et de
la France a été et tout à fait
lamentable
c'est pourquoi la proposition de
résolution qui nous est soumise et
véritablement la bienvenue mais il ne
faut pas seulement mettre en cause le
dictateur à lièvre qui préside
l'Azerbaïdjan il faut aussi je dirais
même surtout mettre en cause le turc
Erdogan qui sème la zizanie un peu
partout autour de la Turquie il s'en
prend à la Grèce ils s'en prend au kurde
ils sont il intervient en Syrie il
occupe un une partie de la Syrie et bien
entendu
ce turc Erdogan n'a jamais accepté de
reconnaître le génocide de
1915 il ne l'a jamais désavoué et on
peut même dire qu'il l'a approuvé et je
suis sûr qu'il ne serait certainement
pas mécontent de faire un second
génocide en ce qui concerne l'Arménie et
pourquoi pas un troisième génocide face
au kurde
si on compare la situation de l'Ukraine
et celle de l'Arménie l'attitude de
l'OTAN et de lu et de l'Union européenne
est tout à fait discriminatoire au
détriment de l'Hermine pire
je vais je peux même en donner quelques
exemples on a par exemple exclué la
Russie du Conseil de l'Europe par contre
on n'a pas du tout exclu la Turquie de
l'OTAN et on n'a pas non plus exclu la
Turquie et l'Azerbaïdjan du Conseil de
l'Europe donc ça veut dire qu'on la
prouve on approuve leur action pire
encore on a intégré la Turquie et
laserbaïdjan dans la communauté
politique européenne pourquoi est-ce que
le turcardo-guent et son complice
d'Azerbaïdjan se gênerait-il si nous
cautionnons par notre action par
l'action de nos états leurs exactions
les crimes de guerre qu'il commettent et
leur volonté en fait de détruire
l'Arménie et comble comble de la
situation on a même doublé les achats de
gaz naturel à
l'Azerbaïdjan donc en fait on les
remercie on remercie l'Azerbaïdjan de
commettre des crimes de guerre
d'agresser l'Arménie de associé avec la
Turquie pour essayer de faire
disparaître l'Arménie et bien moi ce que
je voudrais dire c'est que véritablement
l'Union européenne est en dessous tout
le gouvernement de français dans cette
situation a été en dessous tout parce
que on tient de temps en temps quelques
belles paroles mais on ne fait rien
quand on compare ce qui a été fait en
Arménie en Ukraine et ce qui est fait en
Arménie on se dit manifestement la
France ou tout au moins le gouvernement
français cautionne l'Union européenne
cautionne on va rendre visite au
dictateur d'Azerbaïdjan on le remercie
bah pourquoi est-ce qu'il se gênerait
c'est honteux et tous les crimes de
guerre qui sont commis par l'Azerbaïdjan
avec le soutien de la Turquie et bien il
y a une responsabilité morale des
dirigeants de l'Union européenne et des
dirigeants des différents États
européens dont la France
merci chers collègues à part le
maintenant à Monsieur André Guillaume
pour le Rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
et pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
le 9 novembre dernier à Toulon le
président de la République présentait sa
nouvelle revue stratégique nationale
soulignant à cette occasion que
l'agression contre l'Ukraine risque de
préfigurer de plus vaste réalité
géopolitique à l'avenir que nous n'avons
nul raison d'accepter avec fatalisme et
que nous n'entendons pas subir avec
passivité
dans cet esprit la proposition de
résolution qui nous est présentée
aujourd'hui nous invite à ne pas
accepter la fatalité d'un conflit bien
que celui-ci touchant au premier rang
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan illustrent
également un jeu d'influence entre la
Russie et la Turquie
ces deux pays ont le sait ont des
aspirations dans le Caucase une région
stratégique qui relie la mer Caspienne à
la mer Noire
j'ajouterai concernant l'Arménie que
l'on ne peut pas nier sa dimension
européenne créée par des liens d'amitié
et qu'une proximité culturelle qui a
toujours conduit la France à porter un
regard les plus attentifs sur sa
situation
de la première guerre remportée en 1994
par les Arméniens à celle dite des 44
jours de l'automne 2020 gagner cette
fois-ci par l'Azerbaïdjan le bilan
humain est tragique les exactions
commises notamment par les soldats azéri
contre les Arméniens renvoient aux
douloureux souvenir du génocide arménien
de 1915
s'écrivent nous devons pas rester
impunis et certainement pas être
documenté par Bakou comme la demandé le
porte-parole de la Commission européenne
au sujet d'une vidéo mettant en scène
des soldats violentés et assassinés une
nouvelle fois en septembre dernier les
hostilités ont repris malgré l'accord
tripartite obtenu en 2020 sous l'égide
de Moscou à cet égard doit-on penser que
l'Azerbaïdjan est profité des
difficultés de la Russie a sur l'Ukraine
pour lancer une offensive
peut-être mais la réalité c'est aussi
que le président
alliévore d'une armée soutenue
matériellement par la Turquie et
alimentée par des drones israéliens
souhaité depuis plusieurs mois que soit
déposé la question des frontières ainsi
que celle des statuts du haut Karaba
j'ajouterai que Bakou s'est souvent en
orgueille les quatre résolutions
adoptées par l'ONU en 1983 rappelant les
habilités des frontières dans ce climat
il faut reconnaître que les quatre
dernières rencontres organisées à
Bruxelles depuis 2021 et celle du 6
octobre dernier à Prague lors du premier
sommet de la communauté politique
européenne ont échoué cependant il ne
faut pas renoncer et tout doit être mis
en oeuvre comme nous y invite la
proposition de résolution pour respecter
le cesser le feu du 9 novembre 2020 le
couloir du lâcher doit être sécurisé et
redevenir le pont qu'il était entre
l'Arménie et le haut Karaba
en revanche gardons-nous de donner à
cette guerre des ressorts religieux qui
ne traduisent pas une réalité
géographique
complexe hérité d'une histoire ancienne
il n'y a pas de croisade islamiste mais
certainement des velléités de conquête
de reconquête territoriales le conflit
du haut Caraba est en effet le fruit
d'un découpage des Britanniques non
réglés à la conférence de paix de 1919
une faille que les Soviétiques ont
exploités par la suite toutes ces
difficultés passées et présentes ne doit
pas décourager la communauté
internationale à empêcher de poursuivre
l'objectif de paix dans cette zone du
Caucase Sud d'autant plus que l'Arménie
se dit prête à avancer des propositions
comme elle vient de le faire avec un
projet de zone des militarisée
le RDSE soutient le gouvernement et le
chef de l'État dans le recherche d'une
issue diplomatique que ce soit avec
l'appui du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
ou de l'Union européenne le tout dans un
souci d'équilibre entre les deux parties
dans ce contexte mes chers collègue le
RDSE est bien naturellement insensible à
la situation de l'arsac en toile de fond
notre soutien aux Ukrainiens nous impose
le même devoir moral à l'égard des
Arméniens victimes des victoires des
attaques azéri une grande partie des
membres du groupe votre en proposition
de cette résolution d'autres membres
s'abstiendront afin que la France puisse
y jouer un rôle d'arbitre c'est souvent
ce qu'on attend d'elle je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et maintenant la
parole est à Madame Valérie Boyer pour
le groupe des Républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est encore avec émotion inquiétude et
même colère que je prends la parole ici
le 29 janvier 2001 le président Chirac
pour la loi reconnaissance génocide
arménienne 1915 11 ans après dans cette
même assemblée était voté le
textosportel Assemblée nationale sur la
pénalisation du négationnisme
reconnaître un crime de génocide est
aussi rouvrir les pages sombres de notre
histoire commune celle des Arméniens
massacrés celle de l'industrialisation
de la mort à grande échelle avec un
objectif l'anéantissement d'un peuple
celui c'est redécouvrir la passivité
mondiale face à des régimes sanguinaires
et génocidaires cela réduit nous obliger
à plus de vigilance pour que plus aucun
peuple ne subisse ses horreurs et que
ceux qui ont été victimes de cette haine
puis cette définitivement protégée je me
permets de saluer ici la diplomatie
parlementaire puisque en 2020 sous
l'égide de Gérard Larcher Bruno
Retailleau et de tous les présidents de
groupe de cette assemblée nous avons
voté la reconnaissance de l'arc Sarthe
les Arméniens ont dû dès septembre 2020
en effet de nouveaux compter leurs morts
et les corps mutilés par les
bombophosphores et des bons battles
fragmentation au Karaba cette guerre
asymétrique qui a tant fait de mort
malgré nos alertes malgré les votes des
deux assemblées malgré les cris des
armésiens notre gouvernement a préféré
la neutralité il le montre encore
aujourd'hui sa passivité comme la
souligner le président retaillau pendant
la guerre des carottes quatre jours le
ministre des Affaires étrangères prenait
la neutralité aujourd'hui il semble
indifférent à cet appel du Sénat
à quoi cela sert-il de proclamer le 24
avril une journée nationale pour
aujourd'hui être dans la neutralité
soyons cohérents la communauté
internationale s'est rangée derrière le
mutile et la passivité également et
tandis qu'à bas coût le 10 décembre 2020
le président Erdogan rando hommage à
Anvers Pacha ministre de la guerre en
1915 et architecte du génocide et
s'engageant à poursuivre son œuvre comme
si le drame des Arméniens devait encore
se répéter et face à la passivité de la
communauté internationale pleinement
mobilisée à juste titre par l'Ukraine
lazerbaïdjan soutenu par la Turquie
s'attaque non plus à l'arc Sark mais à
la république souveraine d'Arménie
plus de 200 soldats Arméniens et civils
ont été massacrés en quelques heures
après les plus de 600 plus de 6500 morts
de la guerre des 44 jours en 2020 des
crimes de guerre firmant exhibées sur la
toile par des militaires azerbaïdjanais
se finement dans leurs œuvres de viol de
torture de démembrement toujours la même
barbarie toujours les mêmes crimes
toujours la même passivité des
démocratises occidentales et surtout
européenne même si l'histoire est un
perpétuel recommencement elle ne doit
pas être un renoncement éternel ces
crimes de guerre doivent être punies
nous nous y trompons pas nous sommes
bien face à une nouvelle guerre de
conquête aux portes de l'Europe il y a
bien sûr depuis la fin de l'Union
soviétique la question du statut de
l'arc Sarthe ce territoire dans la
majorité arménienne vit sous la menace
permanente du nettoyage ethnique des
injures des incursions et des opérations
de terreur mais il y a désormais
également la question des frontières de
la République d'Arménie en effet le
président autocrate Imane à liev ne se
contente plus de massacrer des Arméniens
de l'arsac mais attaque le territoire de
l'armén un état reconnu par la
communauté internationale d'ailleurs
l'Institut Lemkin pour la prévention des
génocides a lancé il y a un mois un
troisième une troisième alerte en moins
d'un an cette barbarie s'inscrit dans la
logique génocidaire bien présente dans
le Caucase et n'oublions pas
l'arménophobie le racisme d'État
pratiqué par l'Azerbaïdjan avec le
soutien de la Turquie qui n'a pas
vocation à s'arrêter aux frontières de
ce pays n'oublions pas que c'est
l'Europe aussi qui est menacée de la
Grèce notamment mais aussi Chypre occupé
depuis 1974 par la Turquie c'est même là
que alia et Erdogan ont fêté leur sombre
victoire de 2020
a toujours déclaré vouloir chasser ses
chiens d'Arméniens
Erdogan les appellent les restes de
l'épée évoquant le génocide de 1915
alors demandons-nous pourquoi l'Europe
qui refuse à juste titre toute
compromission avec la Russie dans la
guerre en Ukraine se contente d'être
spectatrice de cette guerre en Arménie
la vie des Arméniens vaut-elle moins que
celle des Ukrainiens rappelons-le fin
juillet alias a obtenu un blanc fin de
la Commission européenne sous la forme
d'un accord gazier indécent prévoyant le
doublement de livraison de gaz à
l'Europe
Ursula anderleyens voit d'ailleurs en
allièvre je la cite un partenaire fiable
sur lequel on peut compter quel
indécence j'invite la président de la
Commission à se rendre comme nous sur
les tombes de ses enfants massacrés de
nos alliés Arméniens
en quoi l'Azerbaïdjan dirigé depuis plus
de 30 ans par le clan à lièvre qui
pratique la diplomatie de la menace qui
est à la tête de la caviar connection ou
des journalistes sont emprisonnés et
mais qui a comme ami un membre de l'OTAN
qui est la Turquie en quoi en quoi
l'Azerbaïdjan peut-il être invité à la
table des négociations malgré le sang
qu'il a sur les mains aussi mes chers
collègues cette guerre ne témoin telle
pas de la lâcheté des
nations-occidentales qui fabriquant
derrière le principe de neutralité n'ont
jamais clairement défendu la position de
l'harmonie comment a-t-on pu abandonner
cette guerre emblématique des chrétiens
d'Orient qui essaient de survivre au
milieu d'un environnement hostile au nom
des valeurs qui sont les nôtres et pour
lesquelles nous défendons l'Ukraine il
faut sauver l'Arménie cette tradition
universaliste humaniste de défense des
droits de l'Homme de lutte contre les
discriminations et de protections des
libertés fondamentales existent de nous
parlementaires que nous soutenions les
Arméniens aussi je vous invite à voter
au-delà de tous nos clivages politiques
cette résolution
et je voudrais vous citer l'évangile de
saint Luc qui disait s'il se taisent les
pierres crieront aujourd'hui c'est
églises
détruites ces traces de l'Arménie
effacée nous oblige à ne pas les laisser
dans la solitude qui est la leur il faut
je les avoir des azerbaïdjanais il faut
exiger des sanctions contre
l'Azerbaïdjan soyons au rendez-vous de
l'histoire il sera trop tard après pour
verser des larmes de crocodile
préservons l'honneur de la France en
étant aux côtés des Arméniens avec
lesquels nous avons des liens qui sont
bien plus anciens que qui remontent à
plusieurs siècles
votons et agissons pour que les
Arméniens puissent s'envain vivre libre
et en paix en sécurité sur leur terre
nous avons trop tardé
merci
et maintenant la parole du terme
Monsieur Joël guerriot pour le groupe
Les Indépendants Républiques et
territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis
seulement un mois les canons se sont
arrêtés la rivalité entre l'Arménie et
les herbaïdjan remonte à plus d'un
siècle en 1992 c'est constitué le groupe
de Mings afin de sceller par la
négociations une solution politique au
conflit comment pouvons-nous admettre
qu'après 30 années la démonétation des
frontières est le déminage des
territoires ne sont toujours pas réglés
la paix ne peut pas reposer sur un statu
quo au risque permanent de reprise des
hostilités les accords de cessez-le-feu
et de paix en 1994 le démontre une pète
trompeuse nuit plus qu'une guerre
ouverte
la proposition de résolution dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui a pour objectif
que nous partageons de rétablir une paix
durable la question qui se pose est de
savoir comment optimiser nos chances d'y
parvenir le multiré le multilatéralisme
et la négociation politique sont
incontournables pour aboutir à des
avancées solides et résoudre
définitivement un conflit la France en
tant que membre permanent au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et de l'OSCE peut-elle
agir unilatéralement à l'encontre des
obligations internationales quelles sont
attachée en particulier la non-ingérence
dans les affaires des pays
notre pays doit œuvrer pour que
l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Arménie reconnaissent
mutuellement la souveraineté politique
et géographique et l’inviolabilité des
frontières internationales de chacun
conformément à la charte des Nations
Unies c'est exactement l'objet de la
réunion Quadriparti entre l'Arménie
l'Azerbaïdjan la France et l'Union
européenne qui s'est tenue le 7 octobre
dernier à Prague nous devons ici saluer
la l'initiative du président Macron
cette rencontre a permis des avancées
autour de la délimitation des frontières
entre les deux pays il a été convenu de
mettre en place une mission civile de
l'Union européenne le long de la
frontière pour une durée de 2 mois cette
mission a commencé il y a une semaine il
me paraît prématuré de prendre
aujourd'hui des positions avant de
connaître les conclusions officielles de
cette mission en attendant la France
doit poursuivre son action afin de
contribuer à faire converger les points
de vue en toute neutralité et
impersialité comme elle a fait
lucidement et discrètement entre Israël
et le Liban les deux pays en guerre
étaient depuis 80 ans et ils ont signé
un accord historique pour la
délimitation de leurs frontières il y a
quelques semaines ce n'est pas la
position de tous les acteurs à cet écart
le soutien de la Turquie à l'Azerbaïdjan
pour des raisons idéologiques et
stratégiques et son application dans les
agressions ne font que compliquer la
situation conflictuelle de même il nous
semble indispensable que le retour des
populations déplacées par les combats et
la libération des prisonniers de guerre
puissent se faire en toute sécurité sous
la supervision supervision des Nations
Unies
à cet égard nous demandons que les
forces de maintien de la paix de l'ONU
soit déployé tout au long des frontières
et des zones disputées en remplacement
des forces russes qui ont échoué dans
leur mission contenu lors de l'accord de
cessez-le-feu le 10 novembre 2020 bien
sûr les auteurs des
atrocités et des crimes de guerre
doivent être jugés devant une
juridiction internationale la France et
l'Europe doivent multiplier leur
pression dans ce sens car jusqu'à
présent ni l'Arménie ni lesherbaïdjan
reconnaissent la juridiction du Tribunal
pénal international ce qui empêche la
création d'un tribunal spécial dans les
meilleurs délais comme le souhaite la
résolution l'unité du Conseil de
sécurité est requise il convient ici de
s'interroger quant à la position que
prendra la Russie alors qu'elle s'est
opposé à la question syrienne
la culture arménienne est considérée
comme une des plus anciennes au monde la
société Azerbaïdjan est multiethnique
multi religieuses et multiculturelle
nous devons respecter l'identité de
chaque peuple la paix se construit dans
l'acceptation de l'autre notre rôle
c'est de promouvoir des valeurs de paix
de fraternité qui permettent de
retrouver entre les Arméniens et les
Algérie des relations qui ne sont plus
malheureusement celle d'aujourd'hui nous
devons éviter d'alimenter des haines en
ouvrant la voie la compréhension Muelle
en ce sens je ne suis pas certain que
cette résolution servait de l'Arménie en
éloignant la France de la médiation
on peut être on peut ne pas avoir le
même la même opinion mon cher Bruno la
proposition de résolution que nous
examinons aujourd'hui vise à mettre fin
à complexe conflit or le manque
d'impertialité risque de compromettre
notre position de médiateur et notre
légitimité auprès de l'Azerbaïdjan et de
l'Arménie je ne suis pas certain non
plus que cela sert les intérêts du
Premier ministre Nicole machignon qui
fait face à des manifestants qui se sont
soutenus par la France accentuant le
risque d'une reprise des hostilités en
freinant les négociations en cours les
indépendants n'auront pas sur ce texte
une position de groupe chacun de ces
membres votera selon ses convictions
merci chers collègues et maintenant la
parole du président Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre
la proposition de résolution que nous
examinons aujourd'hui initié par le
président Retailleau fait suite à la
rupture par lazerbaïdjan du Cécile feu
du 10 novembre 2020 qui m'était fin aux
opérations militaires dans le haut
Caraba
comme nous avions dénoncé l'invasion du
haut-karaba par l'armée azéri nous
condamnons les affrontements frontaliers
initiés au mois d'août et septembre par
les forces militaires azéries qui ont
fait 286 victimes
l'Azerbaïdjan devra en outre
vraisemblablement répondre devant les
tribunaux arts internationaux des
probables crimes de guerre commis à
l'encontre des soldats Arméniens une
enquête internationale doit être
diligentée sans délai pour qualifier ses
exactions nous réitérons notre soutien
inconditionnel au peuple arménien dont
la nation le territoire et la culture
doivent impérativement être préservés et
qui doit être garantie dans son droit à
vivre en paix et en sécurité
dans cette perspective nous nous
inscrivons dans les mots forts du
président de la République qui a rappelé
que la France ne lâcherait jamais
l'Arménie
la reprise de ce conflit territorial
vieux de trois décennies moins de 2 ans
après la fin de la guerre de 2020 est
une nouvelle conséquence des
déstabilisations géopolitiques
provoquées par l'invasion russe en
Ukraine ainsi comme à leur habitude
l'Azerbaïdjan et la Turquie tentent par
tous les moyens de profiter de la guerre
en Europe pour pousser leurs avantages
c'est ainsi que l'Azerbaïdjan a profité
de la rupture de fournitures de gaz
russe au pays européens pour proposer
ses services des bouchons sur l'accord
entre Bruxelles et Bakou signé le 18
juillet dernier visant à doubler les
importations de gaz azéri dans l'Union
cet accord a été dénoncé par des
parlementaires français de tout bord
dont les écologistes mais tout à sa
dépendance aux hydrocarbures l'Europe la
transfert du dictature impérialiste à
une autre
tant que nous n'aurons pas massivement
engagé la sortie des hydrocarbures
l'autonomie stratégique du continent
demeurera une chimère pourtant dans le
contexte géopolitique actuel fragilisée
militairement isolé diplomatiquement la
Russie ne peut demeurer le seul garant
de la paix au sud Caucase il faut que la
communauté internationale par le biais
des Nations Unies plutôt que par celles
du groupe de misk dévitalisé prennent
les dispositions nécessaires pour
permettre l'effectivité du CSFE et la
construction d'une paix durable au
Karaba si la nécessité l'impose et si la
cohabitation avec la force intervention
russe est possible il faudra déployer
une force d'interposition internationale
sous égide onusienne
car et c'est toute la difficulté de la
période il n'est pas envisageable
d'envisager une quelconque intervention
dans la région sans composer avec la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine si une
première médiation initiée par les
États-Unis et l'Union européenne le 2
octobre dernier avait permis la
libération de 17 prisonniers Arméniens
c'est un sommet tripartite organisé par
la Russie qui a débouché sur un
engagement de laserbaïdjan et de
l'Arménie à ne pas recourir à la force
avant que les États-Unis ne tentent de
reprendre la main avec une réunion des
ministres des Affaires étrangères le 7
novembre
cette fragile construction d'un traité
de paix encore illustré par les échanges
de tirs de la semaine dernière qui plus
est dans un contexte international
extrêmement troublé doit être encouragé
par tous les moyens cette pacification
de la région est une nécessité vitale
pour l'Arménie qui ne paraît pas en
mesure de faire face à un regain des
tensions militaires ce constat posé si
le groupe écologiste partage de
nombreuses demandes de la présente
proposition il ne juge pas opportun
d'inviter le gouvernement français a
renforcé les capacités de défense de
l'Arménie les juves même paradoxal de
faire figurer une telle demande dans une
résolution visant à établir une paix
durable
comment la France membre du groupe de
Miss pourrait jouer un quelconque
médiatrice dans la région
si elle devenait ainsi partie prenante
du conflit si la France doit jouer le
rôle que nous appelons de nos vœux sur
tous les bancs de moteurs aux Nations
unies pour que la communauté
internationale tout entière garantissent
la paix dans le sud cocase et ainsi la
Prévert
d'Arménie elle ne peut pas jouer une
autre partition que celle de la
diplomatie pour permettre à la France de
revenir dans le jeu diplomatique il nous
apparaissait pertinent que le
gouvernement reconnaissent la République
d'Arzac et utilise cette reconnaissance
comme un levier de négociation pour
obtenir rapidement un statut juridique
internationalement reconnu pérenne et
protecteur pour le haut Karaba nous
avions signé et voter la précédente
résolution sénatoriale de 2020
pour ces mêmes raisons précisément nous
nous sommes nous obtiendrons sur la
présente résolution qui ne nous semble
pas compatibles avec le rôle que doit
jouer la France dans l'effort de
construction d'une paix durable cela
même de protéger durablement et
effectivement l'Arménie et son peuple
merci merci j'ai un président donc la
part les maintenant à Madame Nicole
Duranton pour le groupe
desocrates progressistes et indépendant
et pour 6 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le conflit
qui oppose la République d'Arménie et la
République d'Azerbaïdjan s'inscrit dans
la durée puisque plusieurs épisodes de
violence ont eu lieu depuis la
proclamation de l'indépendance du haut
Karaba en 1981 la présente proposition
de résolution appelle le gouvernement au
paragraphe 17 à agir pour faire
respecter le cessez-le-feu du 9 novembre
2020 plus largement elle vise à faire
appliquer au paragraphe 22 des réponses
les plus fermes contre l'Azerbaïdjan
enfin et ces derniers points requier
toute notre attention elle réaffirme au
paragraphes 27 la nécessité de
reconnaître la République du haut Karaba
elle va plus loin que le simple retrait
des troupes azériques en portant
également le sujet du rapatriement des
prisonniers de guerre au paragraphe 19
et de l'élimination des discriminations
raciales au paragraphe
le président de la République Emmanuel
Macron a eu samedi un échange
téléphonique avec son homologue
azerbaïdjani à l'issue duquel les deux
dirigeants ont souhaité maintenir une
étroite coordination il s'entretiendra
également avec le Premier ministre
arménien en marge du Sommet de la
Francophonie à Djerba dans quelques
jours le 19 novembre cette voie la voie
du dialogue permet d'avancer de façon
concrète avec les deux parties il faut
rappeler cette échéance et privilégier
le dialogue entre dirigeants
la France souhaite s'inscrire dans une
position de conciliation des intérêts et
permettre le dialogue constructif entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan les deux
États ont tenu lundi 7 novembre des
discussions à Washington sous l'égide
des États-Unis quelques heures après de
nouveaux bombardements frontaliers dans
un conflit qui a fait des centaines de
morts ces derniers mois la France a
souhaité maintenir une étroite
coordination dans le sillage du sommet
de Prague qui avait réuni le 6 octobre
dernier en marge de la première réunion
de la communauté politique européenne le
président alien et le Premier ministre
pachinien le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron a salué l'effet
stabilisateur de la mission civile de
l'Union européenne le long de la
frontière avec l'Azerbaïdjan le
déploiement de cette mission avait été
décidé lors du sommet de Prague le
président a également réaffirmé la
pleine disposition de la France a
accompagné le processus de normalisation
des relations entre les deux pays et à
œuvrer pour une solution politique dans
la région qui puisse permettre à la paix
de s'installer durablement
il est vrai que l'Azerbaïdjan a rompu le
cesser le feu conclut le 9 novembre
dernier avec l'Arménie et à deux
reprises au début du mois d'août et plus
récemment dans la nuit du 12 au 13
septembre ce faisant l'Azerbaïdjan a
fait le choix de l'emploi de la force
plutôt que celle de la voix diplomatique
pour négocier avec l'Arménie les
conditions d'une paix durable au Karaba
il est faux de dire que la France
demeure inactive puisque à la suite de
cette nouvelle offensive elle a demandé
au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU qu'elle
présidait alors de se réunir avec le
soutien de la Turquie l'Azerbaïdjan a
contraint l'Arménie à abandonner la
route exitante par le couloir de la
Chine s'est étroite bande de 5 km qui
relie le haut Karaba à l'Arménie le haut
représentant de l'Union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères et la politique
de sécurité Monsieur Joseph Borel a
appelé à la retenue il faut veiller à ne
pas mettre en échec les négociations
engagées du sel entre les deux parties
sous l'égide de l'Union européenne
depuis quelques mois si il est vrai que
nous que nous importons beaucoup de gaz
d'Azerbaïdjan depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine cet intérêt économique
ne doute pas être retenu comme le
déterminant majeur de notre action celle
de la France pays des droits de l'homme
qui a toujours su prendre et tenir des
engagements courageux une résolution
résoudra-t-elle plus efficacement le
conflit que la diplomatie entre nos
représentants la question est ouverte le
groupe RDPI n'a pas consigné cette PPR
avec mes collègues nous sommes hautement
préoccupés par la situation dans le haut
Karaba et condamnons fermement les
graves incidents survenus dernièrement
dans le secteur du couloir de la Chine
bien que nous partageions nombre de
constats cette proposition de résolution
réaffirme la nécessité de reconnaître la
République
le gros RDPI estime qu'une telle
reconnaissance
ôterait à la France la possibilité de
jouer un rôle de médiation en vue de
l'établissement d'une paix durable bien
entendu notre groupe appelle au Cécile
le feu au repli des forces azéries et au
respect de l'intégrité territoriale de
l'Arménie
au vu de ces éléments factuels mais
aussi stratégiques la majorité du groupe
RDPI a décidé d'adopter la position
d'une abstention constructive qui ne nie
pas l'urgence mais aimer de sérieux et
profond doute sur l'opportunité d'une
telle proposition des résolutions c'est
une position constante qui est celle du
Quai d'Orsay dans la continuité de la
position de novembre 2020 sur la PPR
portant sur la nécessité de reconnaître
la République du haut Karaba néanmoins
et en toute liberté en fonction de
l'appréciation de chacun certains
collègues de notre groupe voteront en
faveur de cette proposition de
résolution je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole
maintenant à Monsieur Gilbert Luc de
Villeneuve du groupe pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président de monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
diplomatie parlementaire est précieuse
elle permet à des élus d'échanger en
toute bienveillance et de partager leurs
espoirs leurs doutes et leurs angoisses
le groupe d'amitié France Arménie du
Sénat que j'ai l'honneur de préciser
présidé et qui est l'un des plus actifs
de la Haute Assemblée grâce à
l'engagement de tous ces membres
entretient avec son homologue de
l'Assemblée nationale arménienne des
relations suivies et empruntent d'une
profonde et réciproque fraternité
nos amis députés Arméniens parce qu'ils
ont confiance en nous nous livrent avec
une grande franchise leur réflexion sur
la situation de leur pays par le passé à
plusieurs reprises notamment en 2019 ils
nous ont alerté sur les risques d'une
agression militaire
leur crainte était fondée nous les avons
relayés auprès des autorités françaises
mais elles n'ont pas été entendues lors
de notre dernier rencontre à Erevan en
septembre dernier et je tiens à
remercier ici Brigitte de VESA Etienne
plan pierre ouzulias de leur présence et
engagement tous les quatre nous avons
été bouleversés par leur désespoir et
leur désespérance abandonner par la
Russie oubliez par l'Europe il meurtri
par le voyage de la présidente de la
Commission européenne à Bakou
l'Arménie leur semblait perdu
de nos échanges je tiens en évoquer au
moins trois
le premier imposer à l'Azerbaïdjan de
réintégrer ces positions du 9 novembre
2020 le deuxième sécurisé la frontière
de l'Arménie avec l'Azerbaïdjan par une
force d'interposition le troisième
effectivement donner les moyens à
l'Arménie d'assurer la sécurisation de
ces frontières
la résolution qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui n'est pas un pamphlet contre
l'Azerbaïdjan ou une éloge à l'Arménie
il s'agit de défendre la paix il s'agit
de défendre nos valeurs démocratiques
nous participons à des groupes d'amitié
non pas pour avoir le plaisir de
découvrir de nouveaux pays où les
visiter mais pour
œuvrer ou renforcement des liens qui
nous unissent et attester de leurs
difficultés c'est donc avec une certaine
solennité et le devoir moral de
témoigner du sentiment d'urgence absolu
qui occupe les esprits de nos collègues
parlementaires que je tiens à m'adresser
au 39 membres du groupe d'amitié France
Arménie à l'ensemble de notre assemblée
et bien sûr au gouvernement français
l'Arménie a besoin de nous de notre
attention de notre soutien sachez que
même dans le plus petit village de
l'Arménie notre dernière résolution a
été entendu et reçu avec espoir
dans les restes d'une petite maison de
la campagne d'harssart en décembre 2020
accueilli avec ce qui restait quelques
pommes et du pain un homme me disait à
propos de la résolution du Sénat la
France pense encore à nous nous vivons
encore jamais n'ont jamais une
résolution parlementaire ne consolera la
souffrance des familles disparues
jamais elle ne fera oublier la
désolation de ces cimetières au ton
gravés de visage de soldats si jeunes
jamais ne ramènera l'allégra
l'allégresse dans ses vignes et ses
vergers ravagés par la guerre jamais ne
séchera les larmes de ces populations
chassées des terres de leur ancêtre et
jamais elle ne ramènera dans son foyer
le jeûne qui a donné sa vie pour que
triomphe dans cette partie du monde la
démocratie mais soyons certains mes
chers collègues que DE TOUTE l'Arménie
le vôtre de notre cela est attendu comme
un message d'espoir par un peuple tant
de fois meurtri par des par les
catastrophes de l'histoire et qui
aspirent encore plus aujourd'hui à vivre
en paix pour poursuivre son destin sur
et dans ces terres
la parole est maintenant je suis Alain
casabone pour le groupe de Union
centriste
et qui a 4 minutes
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues
tout d'abord je tiens à remercier les
présidents retailleux Cambon d'être à
l'initiative cette résolution ainsi que
le président Marseille qui apporte par
sa consignature de soutien à notre
groupe bien sûr au fur et à mesure
qu'avant sa discussion nous sommes
amusés à faire des redites mais je crois
qu'il n'est pas inutile de dire de
redire de redire la tâchement que nous
portons à
l'Arménie et ainsi donner peut-être plus
de force à notre résolution
le Sénat a toujours été au rendez-vous
lorsqu'il s'est agit de défendre
l'Arménie et les Arméniens je pense
notamment à notre vote à la quasi
inanimité de la résolution sur la
nécessité de reconnaître la République
du carabate du karabatch en 2020
2 ans après la signature du feu conclut
entre Bakou et Van le conflit n'est
toujours pas résolu et la situation
reste extrêmement tendue
alors que les regards du monde entier se
restent figés sur le conflit ukrainien
il est pourtant urgent d'agir dans cette
région du Sud Caucase
la particularité de ce pardon
faut classer les feuilles dans l'ordre
n'est-ce pas le désordre
dans la nuit des 12-17 12 13 septembre
c'était événement a été rappelé dont je
ne fais que le redire il y avait eu
cette agression de l'armée azérie qui a
fait près de 286 morts
pourtant pour résoudre ce conflit
plusieurs tables de négociations étaient
ouvertes limitant hélas l'efficacité de
l'action internationale parce que non
coordonnées
du coderus le 31 octobre dernier
Vladimir Poutine a réuni à Sotchi le
président allieve et premier ministre
pachinian pour essayer sans grand espoir
de continuer à ce cadre du côté de
Washington la semaine dernière Anthony
blanquin le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a réuni les ministres des
Affaires étrangères des belligents enfin
du côté européen Charles Michel et
Emmanuel Emmanuel Macron ont été à
l'initiative d'une mission d'observation
qui a conclu naturellement que
laserbachan aille mené des attaques
agressives contre l'Arménie
les efforts de sobriété
pardon encore j'ai mis la carte avant la
la particularité de ce conflit et que
les puissances cherchent à se poser en
médiatrice mais en faisant primer la
concurrence plus que la collaboration
alors que les Occidentaux ont su s'unir
et prendre des décisions et des
sanctions communes pour le conflit
ukrainien il devient nécessaire que la
communauté internationale prenne ses
responsabilités pour que la paix puisse
revenir dans cette partie du Caucase
je comprends très bien que la position
des Européens est pour le moins délicate
vis-à-vis de Bakou alors que le Kremlin
nous a fermé le robinet de gaz nous
sommes tournés vers laserbaïdjan de
venir à trouver l'énergie qui nous sera
nécessaire pour se chauffer cet hiver
président retailleux avait d'ailleurs
écrit récemment un livre que j'avais
beaucoup apprécié et qui évoquait ce
risque de manquer d'énergie pour notre
hiver dès lors pourquoi ces deux poids
de mesure vis-à-vis du régime
totalitaire de limonade après l'Ukraine
et l'Arménie allons-nous créer une
jurisprudence d'annexion dans les
différences et pour reprendre la
citation du marquis talleyran plus qu'un
crime cela serait une faute
ce qui vaut pour la Russie ne vaut-il
pas pour laservation les efforts de
sobriété que nous imposons pour rendre
efficient de nos sanctions ne
peuvent-ils pas s'appliquer au régime
Azé en 2020 ce sont des milliers
Arméniens qui ont été qui ont péri lors
de la guerre au karabates allons-nous
laisser ce conflit sans lisez ainsi nous
devons pas de nos responsabilités vite
la France a toujours été aux côtés des
Arméniens pris en étau entre la Turquie
et la serbaïdjan si nous n'agissons pas
nous serons coupables et nous ne
pourrons pas dire que nous ne savions
pas ainsi le groupe centiste votera dans
sa trigan majorité cette résolution qui
vous invite monsieur le ministre
notamment en son point 27 à tout mettre
en oeuvre pour que l'Azerbaïdjan
s'engage instamment dans un processus de
négociation par la voie diplomatique
afin d'aboutir à l'établissement d'une
paix durable dans le Caucase sud je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues et la parole est à
monsieur Étienne blanc pour le groupe
les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
par cette proposition de résolution
le Sénat honore un engagement ancien de
la France
en faveur de la protection des pays et
des communautés chrétiennes du monde qui
font hélas aujourd'hui l'objet de
persécution
les rapports entre la France et
l'Arménie s'inscrivent dans cette longue
histoire que Charles de Gaulle résumait
par ses simples mots
il y a un pacte 20 fois séculaire entre
la grandeur de la France et la liberté
du monde
alors protéger l'Arménie pour quoi
d'abord parce que c'est une démocratie
dans un océan de dictature violente
la Turquie l'Azerbaïdjan l'Iran pays
frontaliers de l'Arménie violent ces
droits humains fondamentaux qui sont le
socle même de n'être civilisation
épuration ethnique génocide
instrumentalisation de la justice
violence ce sont leurs outils quotidiens
d'exercices du pouvoir
mais l'Arménie elle n'est pas de ce camp
là et loin s'en fout
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
protéger cette si petite démocratie dans
cette région du Caucase
il faut aussi protéger l'Arménie parce
qu'elle est victime et protéger une
victime c'est d'abord et avant tout
désigner son agresseur
l'inhumanité du président Alif ira
jusqu'à exposer dans un parc de Bakou
les trophées sanglant les casques et les
vêtements de ces jeunes Arméniens ces
gamins de 20 ans massacrés par l'armée
d'Azerbaïdjan qui ne fut victorieux que
parce que doté de drôles d'artillerie et
d'armes modernes par la Turquie on peut
être simple suppiété et se prendre pour
un héros enfin il nous faut protéger
l'Arménie car elle est devenue le jouet
d'une rivalité géopolitique qui se
dessine dans la région entre la Russie
et la Turquie
deux pays qui pour l'in considère que
l'Arménie contrarie un paon turquisme
assumé et pour l'autre tente de
conserver une influence au sein d'une
ancienne république soviétique laquelle
influence s'évanouit mais protéger
l'Arménie c'est aussi nous protéger
nous-mêmes face aux fondamentalisme d'un
islam politique totalitaire qui nie
l'altérité
élimine ce qui ne lui est pas semblable
la France doit alors être du côté de
l'altérité du respect des différences de
la protection des minorités tout cela
sous couvert de la défense de la liberté
de penser de croire ou tout simplement
de la liberté de vivre
oui ce que vit aujourd'hui l'Arménie
c'est ce que nous pourrions être appelés
demain à connaître si nous ne défendons
pas ces valeurs universelles auxquelles
nous croyons alors cette résolution elle
propose trois réponses à une question
que je posais au gouvernement le 5
octobre elle propose d'abord de
désavouer la Commission européenne qui
sous la signature de Madame Van derlayen
a signé un accord indigne honteux avec
laserbaïdjan pour s'assurer de livraison
de gaz et de pétrole la France ne peut
pas accepter que soit sacrifié la
liberté du peuple arménien en raison de
son confort hivernal
en cela la proposition d'embargo sur le
gaz et de pétrole et sans doute une
réponse à la hauteur des crimes qui ont
été commis par les herbaïdjan
cette résolution elle vous exhorte
ensuite à renforcer les capacités
défensives de l'Arménie en lui
fournissant ses armes nécessaires à sa
protection il est temps sur ce sujet de
passer de la parole aux actes pour
protéger ce territoire que l'on Cessy
fragile enfin et c'est la demande la
plus pressante de l'Arménie de son
président et de son premier ministre que
nous avions rencontré à Erevan avec le
président Gilbert Luc de vinasse à la
fin du mois de septembre il faut que la
France profite de cette présidente
française du Conseil de sécurité pour
mettre en place cette force
d'interposition tant attendue qui
garantira la souveraineté de l'Arménie
sur son territoire ses frontières la
liberté de son peuple et l'intégrité des
Arméniens du haut Karaba une république
que le gouvernement français serait bien
inspiré enfin de reconnaître alors
oui en honorant cette résolution la
France Sonora dans la protection de ce
peuple arménien qui n'attend de vous
qu'une chose une œuvre de paix
[Applaudissements]
et la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane rue
duguier dernier orateur inscrit pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
c'est le Président Monsieur ministre mes
chers collègues la dignité d'un peuple
réside avant tout dans sa souveraineté
et le respect de l'intangibilité de ses
frontières le peuple arménien en est la
parfaite illustration ce peuple d'un
courage exemplaire qui se bat seul
isolé du reste du monde contre une
coalition
Asie turque et ces mercenaires
djihadistes
qui bombarde des civils
massacre des soldats des armées dans une
forme d'indifférence
oui l'Arménie est en danger de mort
c'est de notre responsabilité première
de la secourir de la protéger
et notre inaction dans ce domaine est
purement inacceptable et suicidaire
l'histoire des hommes c'est d'abord et
avant tout
l'histoire des civilisations et celle-ci
par essence peuvent être mortels
or le peuple arménien
premier état chrétien du monde
appartient plus qu'aucun autre à notre
civilisation à nos racines
judéo-chrétienne
et nous avons aujourd'hui
et le président rotaïo la clairement dit
la désagréable impression
d'un fameux deux poids de mesure
insupportable
au niveau de la politique étrangère de
l'Europe mais également de la France
nous avons infligé
d'énormes sanctions à la Russie
après son agression de l'Ukraine ce
qu'il fallait faire bien évidemment
jusqu'à renoncer à s'alimenter au gaz
russe
mais mes chers collègues
vont nous fait concrètement pour nos
amis arméniens en réalité
disons-le assumons-le pas grand chose
nous nous sommes contentés jusqu'à
présent de simples communiquer de
protestation de badges à la boutonnière
qui malheureusement
n'ont eu aucun effet chez les agresseurs
qui sont véritablement n'ont pas dans
une logique d'apaisement mais dans une
logique dépuration ethnique entamée avec
le génocide de 1915
pire encore
madame vanderleyen
s'est rendu en personne à Bakou pour
célébrer en grande pompe un nouvel
accordier qui doit doubler les
importations de gaz provenant de
laserbaïdjan c'est purement immoral et
abject y aurait-il une hiérarchie dans
les conflits
le président rotaïo tout à l'heure nous
a questionné sur le sujet le sang et les
larmes des arméniales
valent-ils moins que ceux des Ukrainiens
non il ne peut y avoir de géométrie
variable dans notre politique étrangère
il en va de la crédibilité de la voie de
la France ce vieux pays dont la voie
singulière vient du fond des âges
choisir comme fournisseur de gaz
d'azerbalgian pour pallier le manque
d'approvisionnement russe et non
seulement une preuve de renoncement à
nos valeurs mais surtout une immense
faute
géopolitique car cet accord renforce
deux facto
le régime autocratique dictatorial
de surcroît cette décision européenne
alimente l'ambition impérialiste de
Monsieur Erdogan qu'il déploie depuis
plusieurs années à travers notamment une
stratégie de déstabilisation
internationale alors pour conclure mes
chers collègues la question qui se pose
en fait à travers cette proposition de
résolution c'est de savoir si l'Europe
si la France est prête à accepter à ses
portes un nouvel empire ottoman plus
islamique que jamais un nouveau tyran
qui du Caucase à la Méditerranée
imposerait ses visions en quelque sorte
et ton prêt à accepter pour quelques
méga water la disparition d'un peuple
qui nous supplie à genoux de l'aider qui
oserait répondre par l'infirmative à
cette interrogation nous vous proposons
par cette proposition de résolution
d'envoyer un message clair et fort de
répondre non avec la plus grande fermeté
en défendant l'identité et la
souveraineté d'un État il en va de notre
civilisation de notre culture et de nos
racines
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Olivier best ministre et délégué chargé
du Commerce extérieur de l'attractivité
et des Français de l'étranger
chez le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs je voudrais d'abord
excuser la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères qui accompagnent
actuellement le président de la
République au G20 en Indonésie c'est
donc le ministre délégué auprès de la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères qui portera la parole du
gouvernement
la proposition de résolution aujourd'hui
débattue devant votre assemblée porte
sur un enjeu particulièrement important
pour la France
pour l'Europe et qui prend une acuité
particulière après l'agression russe en
Ukraine au mépris de tous les principes
du droit international d'ailleurs à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle
l'Ukraine subit une vague de
bombardements massif sans précédent
visiblement par son intensité et
touchant les infrastructures
énergétiques de plusieurs villes
d'Ukraine
la guerre qui est revenue en Europe par
l'agression russe n'est pas sans
conséquence dans la région du Caucase
qu'elle contribue à déstabiliser elle
n'est pas sans conséquence pour
l'Arménie qui en subit le contrecoup
face aux défauts de légitimité d'une
Russie guerrière pour se poser en
faiseur de paix
ce contexte porteur de risques
d'embrasement nous conduit à redoubler
des forts pour œuvrer à des solutions
permettant une paix et une stabilité
durable dans le Caucase la première
condition de cette stabilité et pour que
les négociations entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan puissent progresser et le
strict respect du cessez-le-feu et le
renoncement au recours à la force pour
régler les différents lors des très
graves affrontements qui sont survenus à
la frontière entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan le 13 et 14 septembre la
France s'est immédiatement mobilisé le
président de la République a été en
contact avec le Premier ministre
arménien Nicole paccinian et avec le
président
azerbaïdjani Ilham à Liège pour appeler
à l'arrêt des combats au respect de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie et
un retrait des positions
occupées par l'Azerbaïdjan
nous avons aussi réuni le Conseil de
sécurité sous présidente française à
deux reprises les 15 et 16 septembre
pour marquer la même exigence nous avons
aussi obtenu l'envoi d'une mission
d'évaluation de l'OSCE du côté arménien
de la frontière
aujourd'hui c'est l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Arménie qui est en jeu
et qui doit être défendu
il n'y aura pas de solution durable sans
respect des principes du droit
international aussi l'un des objectifs
majeurs du président de la République
lorsqu'il a réuni à Prague aux côtés de
Charles Michel le Premier ministre
pacinia et le président Alif a été que
les deux pays confirment leur
attachement à la Charte des Nations
Unies et à la déclaration d'almaata de
1991 par laquelle il reconnaissait
mutuellement leur intégrité territoriale
et leur souveraineté
l'autre résultat majeur de La Réunion de
Prague a été la mise en place d'une
mission civile de l'Union européenne le
long de la frontière avec laquelle
l'Azerbaïdjan a accepté de coopérer
cette mission s'est déployée dès les
lendemains du sommet de Prague pour une
durée de 2 mois l'objectif de cette
mission est établir la confiance et par
ses rapports de contribuer aux
commissions de délimitation des
frontières son déploiement a déjà
contribué à une diminution significative
des incidents et des tensions
salutons l'extrême célérité avec
laquelle l'Union européenne a été en
mesure de déployer ses observateurs et
c'est à Prague enfin qui a eu lieu la
rencontre historique entre le Premier
ministre patchinian et le président turc
Récept Erdogan grâce à l'intermédiation
du président de la République Emmanuel
Macron
la France n'a donc pas ménagé ses
efforts en faveur aussi de la libération
des prisonniers de guerre arménien grâce
aux interventions conjuguées de la
France de l'Union européenne et des
États-Unis trois libérations successives
de prisonniers sont intervenus cette
année nous continuons d’appeler à ce que
tous les prisonniers je dis bien tous
les prisonniers soient remis en liberté
la France est donc pleinement mobilisée
dans ces efforts de médiation aux côtés
de l'Union européenne mais aussi des
États-Unis afin de parvenir à des
solutions négociées sur l'ensemble des
questions en suspens lors d'une réunion
le 7 novembre à Washington une première
session de négociation s'est tenue entre
les parties sur un projet de traité de
paix nous les encourageons à poursuivre
ces négociations de bonne foi ainsi que
celle sur la délimitation de la
frontière qui doit s'opérer exclus
vivement par la voix de la négociation
notre rôle est de facilité c'est pour
parler et d'essayer de contribuer à un
climat de confiance et non de prendre
des mesures de rétorsion à l'égard d'une
partie au risque de renforcer les
risques d'hostilité il existe
aujourd'hui une opportunité pour
parvenir à la paix qui doit être saisi
ce que nous demande aujourd'hui
l'Arménie c'est de continuer à être un
médiateur actif sur tous ces sujets
c'est le message que le ministre
arménien des Affaires étrangères m'a
donné la semaine dernière dans mon
bureau et qui guide notre action
la France continuera également de vrai
au règlement de la question du okarabak
puisque cette question n'est pas réglée
là encore je vous invite à bien écouter
ce que dit le gouvernement arménien et
ce que m'a redit encore le ministre
harajean
Mehdi la chose suivante la question du
haut-karabaq n'est pas une question de
territoire mais de droit
si dans le passé nous plaçons la
question du statut au fondement en
faisant dériver de l'huile les garanties
de sécurité et les droits
désormais nous plaçons les garanties de
sécurité et les droits à la base en en
faisant découler le statut
ces propos courageux du Premier ministre
pacchinian devant le Parlement arménien
le 13 avril dernier ont ouvert un espace
de négociation visant à définir le
contenu de ses droits et de ses
garanties la France soutient cette
approche car il nous appartient pas de
prétendre mieux savoir que le
gouvernement arménien ce qui est dans
l'intérêt de l'Arménie ce qui nous
appartient et de contribuer avec nos
partenaires à ce qui émerge des
solutions dans lesquelles nous ayons
confiance pour garantir que la
population arménienne du haut-karabaque
puisse continuer d'y vivre dans la
sécurité et d'y jouir de tous ses droits
c'est ainsi que nous serons utiles et
solidaires de l'Arménie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
aucun pays sur la scène internationale
aucun pays ne fait davantage que la
France pour soutenir l'Arménie nous le
faisons par fidélité pour nos valeurs
pour notre histoire et pour l'amitié qui
nous lie au peuple arménien
c'est notre devoir notre honneur notre
fierté c'est aussi notre combat pour la
paix et je peux vous assurer que nous
poursuivrons nos efforts de médiation
jusqu'à l'instauration d'une paix
durable je vous remercie
chers collègues nous allons maintenant
procéder au vote sur la proposition de
résolution
sur lequel j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe les
républicains sur l'ensemble de
la proposition la Conférence des
Présidents a décidé que les
interventions des orateurs valaient
explication de vote donc nous pouvons
passer au vote le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande qu'à voter le
scrutin et donc clos
et le résultat du scrutin nous sommes
332 votants
296 exprimés pour la résolution 295
contre 1 la résolution est donc adoptée
[Applaudissements]
j'avais suspendre quelques instants pour
permettre à tous nos collègues et le
gouvernement est déjà là de s'installer
pour l'examen du prochain point d'ordre
du jour donc le débat collectivité la
séance est suspendue